and the other person you play your music
for to get a vibe from is Stevie Nicks
right I mean I'm Reena I played in the
new album yeah when it was finished how
does that work you finish an album and
you call up Stevie Nicks oh I know
you're close to right she was in London
there was some Fleetwood Mac shows in
London and she wakes up pretty late and
she wanted to go to dinner one of the
night so I took its this little Indian
restaurant near my house can you believe
that your life has become that you can
go to dinner which it was pretty crazy
she's probably one of the greatest
songwriters exactly yeah so I just kind
of finished the record and then she said
I want to come hear the album and she
was with like all her ladies she's she's
got a witches coven I don't know which
is which is comment yeah and then they
all came back to the house your house
used yet to my house yeah and I played
in the album and they're so used to like
living nocturnally there you know they
wake up really late and then they kind
of live through the night because
they're you know which is right and so
it's getting to like 3:00 a.m. playing
that behind the album like right and
they're like right in their prime you
know they're really like oh this is like
daytime for us what is that
I mean how does somebody stay up that
late especially you know I don't know
how is she pulling that off I don't know
they left it like six I remember them
walking outside to get a to get car and
the Sun had come up they're like vampire
I was like I'm exhausted and isn't it
weird that when you around somebody as
iconic and famous as Stevie Nicks in a
way you want to please her and you want
to go along with the crowd but they're
there to [ __ ] 6:00 in the morning and
you like Jesus correctly these are
people gonna go home it's really not
that much